There's a lot of talk about the need for
the generations to come to be okay with
being poorer than the generations that
went before. And my point is, well, you
don't need to be. The idea that we can
have such a defined pie that can only
grow at such a
slow rate each year uh to be the true
sustainable economy is an argument only
made by those who are the halves because
they already have most of the slices of
the pie and they don't want to share
them.
The argument that we are trying to make
and I think that we are making possible
is the argument that we can build a much
much bigger pie. In fact, that pi can be
exponentially bigger. And the sliver
that any one of the existing owners of
the current pi have may not increase in
size in terms of the number of degrees
across the the pi that they have. But a
pie that is 100 times bigger than the pi
we have today is well I I can't do the
the maths off the top of my head, but
it's it's way more than 100 times more
valuable to have that same sliver of the
pie. Uh it can just get bigger and
bigger and bigger. And I